[Musique]
le rôle surf le surf à roulettes qui se
pratique sur n'importe quel sol dur ou
cimenté en réalité une ressemble au surf
traditionnels que de très loin la
planche est ici réduite à quelques
centimètres elle n'est plus qu'un
support
nous allons maintenant découvrir les
possibilités du rôle surf ils permettent
en effet outre le virage l'exécution de
nombreuses figures le pédalage par
pivotement successifs sur les ponts
avant et arrière permettent aux surfers
de prendre de la vitesse
le saut est une des figures les plus
difficiles à réaliser à cause du
mouvement de la planchette et nous avons
gardé pour la fin de cette démonstration
une figure qui s'appelle kamikazes et
[Musique]
après le ski sans neige et le patin sur
glace voici donc le surf sans eau et
peut-être que dans quelques années il
aura complètement supplanté la
trottinette
[Musique]